I used to wonder about that how a girl
could go outside with a thong bikini on
and not get arrested for public
indecency because I could see her full
butt yeah like well that's just naked
almost right yeah you can't just put a
piece of thread through your butt crack
and pretend like you're not naked where
are the morals amen my father like I
don't want to be with my father on a
beach yeah with with girls in their
butts hanging out like that makes me
uncomfortable don't those people have
any self-respect or or don't they have
any care for their their family and
they're oh it's just gross there are
nude beaches I don't think kids are
supposed to go to those then that's
because you get you know your your skin
sunlight is really healthy for your skin
so you have a backyard everybody's got
some of a backyard that was the ideal
city people not in cities I mean I live
in the city and if I really need to do
then I can make it happen I'm just
saying but I don't need to do that by
the water it's really really healthy all
that sun that uh salt water we're gonna
see a pendulum swing back in the other
direction because it's gone too far